la concertation a débuté cet été pour la
réhabilitation de l'hyper centre de
saint quentin en yvelines
si le projet est piloté par la
communauté d'agglomération le territoire
concerne bien montigny le bretonneux
l'objectif étant de moderniser ce
quartier bâti dans les années 1980 et
qu'ils répondent aux problématiques du
sage de transport et de nature en ville
d'aujourd'hui la nature et
l'environnement c'est justement l'un des
enjeux de ces élections municipales
montigny le bretonneux aspire à réaliser
sa transition écologique la commune
n'échappe pas au contexte démographique
général et doit faire face à une
population vieillissante
un phénomène accentué par un coût du
logement élevé les jeunes familles et
nîmes antenne peinent à accéder à la
propriété et quittent la ville un enjeu
d'autant plus fort que montigny le
bretonneux accueille de nombreux sièges
d'entreprises comme récemment bmw dans
le quartier du pas du lac dont les
salariés sont en pleine installation
dans ses nouveaux locaux des
constructions de logements dont des
logements sociaux font justement partie
de plusieurs chantiers communaux en
cours celui du forum des arts charles
aznavour à la place de l'ancien collège
bergson livraison prévue en avril 2021
mais également la réfection du club le
village fermé en décembre dernier pour
douze mois de travaux
55 à 60 logements font partie du projet
mais l'événement dont la nouvelle
municipalité aura à s'emparer ce sont
bien sûr les jeux olympiques de 2024
le vélodrome nationale accueillera les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et l'île
de loisirs sell de bmx